last night it was pretty good no it was
just pretty good I only did a magnet
back that's not pretty good that's kind
of like amazing guess who got lucky last
night
myself
I don't think it's funny Angela and
Michael get intimate for the first time
in years just hours after her explosive
Timber tantrum you know I hate how me
and Michael fight but I do believe we
have the best makeup sex there is
[Music]
All We Do
first Angela loves him then she hates
him
and the cycle continues for these two
after that little makeup sesh which I'm
still trying to wrap my head around
Michael still refuses to take down his
Instagram which leaves Angela feeling
played I feel like a piece of like a
horn street that didn't get paid like
prostitutes get more respect than
Michael gave me okay let's not over
exaggerate here let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
I just want to let you know that I
really appreciate your love and support
in the comments I know you don't have to
sit there and type anything but the fact
that you do it means a lot so just know
it's never lost on me and at this point
we're on this journey together my 90 day
fans fam y'all are my day ones okay
wherever this journey takes me just know
you've played a huge part in it
y'all know the rest all right before we
get into Angela and Michael a few
updates
this episode Andre and Libby revealed
they are pregnant again but in real time
they already had the baby and it's a boy
so if you didn't know now you do
congrats to those two
also let me go ahead and give you an
update on Usman and Kim you know last
episode his mom told them she doesn't
support their marriage unless Usman
marries a younger woman first and Kim in
my head I'm like hell no tells Usman
she's not trying to be anybody's second
wife so if they don't get his mom's
blessing they're breaking up
me hey you can go I have adventure to
have beautiful out of 60 women around me
I'm rejecting it because I feel like it
shouldn't be Duty or whatever you should
be loved Usman then proceeds to
basically tell Kim she's lacking in The
Beauty Department
yeah he basically caught her ugly which
was pretty low what woman wants to hear
that from their man
he knew what he was doing by saying that
that's a funny thing to say to me but
now apparently
every time I say apparently I think of
this little kid bro you're spinning
around and apparently every time you get
dizzy apparently he was so cute but yeah
now apparently Kim has reached out to
Usman saying she wants to talk and all
that's going through my mind is Kim
don't be desperate he just intentionally
took a shot at your self-esteem don't
just skim over that the thing that
bothered me is when you were like oh
well I have a hundred women like what is
that to say to me basically I'm doing
you a favor by being with you like what
the [ __ ] is that you're not doing me a
favor I'm a beautiful woman too I'm a
very good person that's right Kim you
tell him who you are don't let him tell
you
do you know how much I'd hurt after
everything we've been through no no
listen I have to tell you that I have
enrollment because you are trying to
tell me that you are ready to break up
with me that's not what I said that's
what you said
I certainly didn't mean what I said to
Usman as a threat I'm trying to make
clear my expectations of what I want out
of this relationship we know that oh
woman is just being difficult
Kim goes on to say she's never going to
allow another man to manipulate her
again after what she's experienced in
the past but what comes next is Usman
doing exactly that manipulating the heck
out of her open your eyes open your eyes
so if you're hot I'm sorry but I say
that to you because you tell me you
should break up so you can make me look
like stupid
what that's how you know he is just
talking let's not forget Usman already
told us his plan I think somebody may
like be accepted he's going to try to
coerce him into the role of a second
wife knowing she doesn't want that she
may not say yes but if he keeps on going
Kimball you say okay if that's the only
way let's just do it as long as you're
not going to leave me so everything he
says next
is a part of the ACT
action I didn't tell you that I'm going
to get married first
they said it you know that I love you
and I'm happy with you just know you're
happy being with me that's why you're
with me I don't ask you to be second
wife
you understand that I understand and I
am ready to make sure that you leave
here smiling or let me say we live here
smiling
you understand
and scene in shocker
they move on
let's go
hmm He'll Do It Again
y'all know me I am not pessimistic but
it seems as if he's already built a
habit of taking Jabs at her confidence
and I'm tired of the little comments
once I think about it the only praise or
compliment I ever hear him tell her is
that she's loyal
and that benefits him
I'm fine fast forward they meet with
usman's mom again to try to get her
blessing one more time and things are
going good surprisingly Kim shows
usman's mom and brother her son Jamal
mom is asking is he all right Mama said
that he's like us
yeah and usman's brother is impressed
when he learns that Kim served in the
military when you see a military man or
a military woman you have that you know
sense of belonging off you guys are one
and you're having some understanding but
then
you know there's always a butt thing
usman's mom reiterates that she's not
giving Usman her blessing to marry Kim
first and reveals she actually has a
young lady right now who is willing and
ready and waiting to marry him and this
young lady wants to meet Usman ASAP I
don't want you to go meet this potential
life while I'm here I don't think that's
right I should not just try to please
you I also need to please my mom I know
not while I'm here I don't think that's
right midnight is no Marina I may end up
seeing her and I don't like her even if
I like her there's no how the connection
if usman's plan works
ah
this is when you say it's just not
working we don't want the same things
it's not clicking which reminds me of
something Nicholas dropped in the
comments quote I hope for Kim she
realizes this is a train wreck their
values are different it's okay for a
relationship to not work right that's so
true it's okay every relationship
doesn't have to be your forever and I've
learned from experience it's better to
be single than to be in a relationship
where you rarely have peace of mind
peace of mind
is everything my mom is asking me to go
and see somebody a woman
is here she's not saying no for me and
Kimberly to be together but let's
let me go and have a young lady that can
give me child then after that I can
carry on with Kimberly whatever I want
to do I know this is going to be a
biggest test but regardless I have to
just convince Kimberly to obey my mom
thinking about himself
if we all have our own lessons to learn
all right let's move on to Angela and
Michael
last night I gave Michael an ultimatum
take the Instagram down or leave it up
and my ass is going home
there's no choice you take it down
because you love me or you keep it up
because you love yourself
shouldn't he love himself too though
it's the morning after Angela's latest
explosion on Michael and the last thing
I expected to see was Michael's head pop
up in her bed Michael came to my room
last night he told me he was going to
take his Instagram down today which gave
me hope that he wasn't frauding me and
wouldn't be an opportunist
my goal is cheesing away and he does
love me
last night when she left me at the
restaurant I couldn't let the night end
like that
despite all the shouting no yelling I
miss my wife so much and guess who got
lucky last night
myself
the fact that he could even get in the
mood after this
my [ __ ] is impressive I hate how me and
Michael fight but I do believe we have
the best makeup sex there is Angela and
Michael go on to give us a bit too much
information about their night and she
finally gets the validation she was
waiting on from Michael about her new
figure
last night it was pretty good no it was
just pretty good I only did a magnet
back that's not pretty good that's kind
of like amazing
when was that I don't know when you was
being a beast I don't know you know
they'll pop these are fake Michael
[Music]
seeing the new body I love it I mean
it's so sexy we have more positions now
when he lays on top of me he could look
down and see the coochie okay just tell
it like it is
like I said TMI TMI I apologize to your
imagination get out of my head get
a phone call me Michael Michael putting
in some work did take Angela's
crankiness away for a bit but oh
Instagram that darn Instagram it's just
way too important
we still got to resolve your social
media
I did tell Angela last night that I was
gonna take down the Instagram to
convince her to be sweet with me but I
really don't intend to take it down
Michael
so Angela is right when she says Michael
lies and goodness after what he
experienced last night he wasn't
concerned about what her reaction would
be
it's like a little kid who just got a
whooping I'm not saying I support
spanking your kids this is just an
analogy but it's like a little kid who
just got a whooping and immediately he
goes to do something else that he knows
is going to cause him to get another one
I told you not to test me of course I
feel bad lying to her but I did it
because I thought if I could put her in
a better mood then it will be better to
talk to her about keeping my social
media
Michael said I'm pulling out all the
tools he goes on to tell Angela the
truth which is that he lied and he's
planning on keeping his social media you
knew exactly what you were doing for you
you know about that oh we've been
through this was your Masterpiece you're
not that goddamn nice Michael you're
nice when you want to be but when
there's something you want to do you
don't give up you want to do it and
you'll take the consequences with me
later
it's not all about you you have a
partner now which is I myself well I've
run out of patience with you
I'm ready to go home
camera that she feels as if Michael used
her for sex
I feel like a piece of like a horn
street that didn't get paid like when
prostitutes get more respect than
Michael gave me and the per usual she
storms off on him you get all this to me
do what you want honey no I'm asking you
a question go back up you get on my
goddamn nerves
she won't delete social media for me so
why should I delete mine for her
if I don't put my foot down I'm never
gonna have anything in this marriage but
all the same time I still love her and I
still want the marriage to work once
Angela gets back to the hotel oh yep get
that out she says she's emotionally
drained which after all of this
you [ __ ]
I would be too I've done a lot for this
man and if he wants to do me like that
[Music]
I'm telling you I can't
I just can't
just want to go home where are the tears
she's wiping away when Michael gets to
the hotel Angela tells him she's not
interested in talking I was like oh you
smother me I'm sorry okay and then he
comes up with this excuse
I thought that you making love to me and
we had passionate sex that you really
wanted to take this thing down yourself
and I felt so loved by you baby it's a
layer of love because I love you a lie
of love
what kind of word is that now Michael
we're starting to see the BS Angela is
talking about that still doesn't justify
her behavior though Angela ends up
leaving the hotel because Michael
wouldn't meanwhile her friend Renee who
joined her on the trip convinces Michael
to join her at the bar and wait for
Angela to calm down I truly care about
Angela and I want Michael to be winning
but I don't think this whole thing is
invented on Instagram I see a lot of
wrong in him and I see a lot of wrong in
her and there's no communication so it's
always going to be a problem because
they need to learn how to communicate
with each other
ding ding spot on Renee
all right next week Michael goes off
after Angela calls Billy the man she's
been dancing with on Tick Tock hi Billy
hey Angel calling uh Angel enjoy my ass
my husband Michael
oh yeah
this guy Angela caused the lion she's
taking it too far please please please
please
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with E.T because we are covering
it all I will see you next time
[Music]